the the other way to look at this whole
thing is to do a mind shift you know I I
interviewed Siri that have you guys have
seen Siri right on the iPhone yeah got
Bob by Apple yeah and I'm hearing that
that's going to be the core of a future
iPhone right and Google's doing the same
thing it's an AI play though it's not AI
but you talk to it uhuh it understands
your language or you could poke at it
and choose things from a menu but really
the cool thing is you talk to it you say
I need a taxi tonight at 8:00 p.m. to
pick me up here at the house and it it
understands it so and you see that it
understood your language and then it
uses artificial intelligence to
understand what was he really trying to
do you know and right and he pulls out
the keywords and the key concepts of of
what I was asking for and then it goes
to web services and right now it doesn't
have many web service it adds 40 or 50
and it but it it brings back information
like hey this taxi company can pick you
up at 800m here's the confirmation
number and here's right here's the taxi
driver's phone number so know houses
this address right you're bridging two
very important Concepts that keep coming
up for us which is the idea that um
there's a shortage of time you never
have enough time and there's too much
information and we're using mobile phone
we're using these less and less and
mobile more and more and I hear that
from every entrepreneur who I uh I
interviewed open table and they said the
mobile usage just
just because people are out you know out
mountain biking or something and they
they have this brain fart hey let's go
to dinner tonight and so they you know
they they poke at a an app on their
iPhone or they talk to Syria and say
find me a restaurant and boom you know
oh yeah these three restaurants have
space tonight and it makes that
reservation right from the cell phone um
spafinder if you want spa treatment or
the spa at the Ritz down here has a
spafinder system that manages their spa
and has a calendar and it's right it's
really interesting open TBL is a
calendar and spotfinder a calendar you
know it's their interface in front of
them it's like oh yeah we have slots on
at 8 o00 on Saturday morning for you to
come in well it's a web service so Siri
could talk to it and say hey this guy
wants a a spa treatment in the morning
to tomorrow morning can you find me a
slot there it you know it negotiates
back and forth and then it goes oh yeah
we found one at8 let's pull that out and
make a reservation and that's something
that doesn't look like a when you're
talking to Siri it ain't looking like a
calendar you know it doesn't look like
that grid Although our data set I would
imagine would be very important for Siri
right well absolutely yeah you know and
so imagine a world where instead of 40
web services or so that siries right now
talking to you know like Fandango Open
Table um you know tax web service Pizza
web service stuff like that what if it
had what if it was all Apple
applications all 250,000 of them
automatically build an API that Siri can
talk to and negotiate with then what
happens to our world when we can talk to
an iPhone and have it negotiate with
everything in the world you know can you
uh change my flight on trip you know and
it knows oh he's on tripet because he
has tripet app let's look at tripet oh
yeah we found the flight let's go to
united.com we know it we know his
frequent flyer mile because he has
United Airlines app you know and boom
all of a sudden you create a magical
experience is the calendar the hub for
all of this well it sure seems like it
because like the Spa Salon has a
calendar that's a hub MH um you know the
restaurant Cella has Open Table you know
down the street and that's a hub and
calendar right you know and what else is
going to be a I'm going to have my
Google Calendar or whatever you know
whatever I find that's cool you know you
guys might take over the world
there we're trying you yeah and plancast
knows where I'm going plancast already
knows all the events I'm going to in the
next year yeah for square knows where
you are yeah for square knows where you
are it's which isn't quite a calendar
but it could be shoving stuff onto a
calendar interface I think is the
calendar the hub for all of this well it
sure seems like it because like the Spa
Salon has a calendar that's a hub um you
know the restaurant Cella has Open Table
you know down the street and that's a
hub and that's calendar right you know
and what else is going to be a cal I'm
going to have my Google Calendar or
whatever you know whatever I find that's
cool you know you guys might take over
the world
there we're trying you know yeah and
plancast knows where I'm going plancast
already knows all the events I'm going
to in the next year yeah for square
knows where you are yeah for square
knows where you are it's which isn't
quite a calendar but it could be shoving
stuff onto calar so when you add mobile
and location everything it changes it
changes what it you know what we can and
social right it Chang and and Siri
hooked that into Siri now what can Siri
do do about that you know already
there's a service called gobi go that
you can say I'm here um where's all the
hiking trails around here right you know
and it's cool it shows it on a map you
know um realtors.com had a map where you
just look at the city oh I want to live
in that part of the city you Circle it
and it shows all the houses available in
that part of the city right you know
and you know and then you hook that into
a calendar you start saying okay I I
have five houses to look at I can't do
all five today let's do two today well
that's a calendar yeah you know let's do
three tomorrow yeah and the calendar
then has to get the realtor you know
could talk to my realtor and say hey I
got to look at houses tomorrow can you
make you know these three houses happen
that's calendar and so there's a
calendar underneath it might not be the
right you might not look at the grid but
your the data is there and the assistant
like Siri that you're talking to is
going to make the deal with you know
she'll talk to my you know the Siri app
will talk to my realtor app and make a
deal and find out that she's available
or not you know